[Music]
with Microsoft's Forza Motorsport 7 and
Sony's GT sport already impressing
racing fans on their respective consoles
you have to wonder about the switch
there are a couple of futuristic racing
games as well as the wonderful Mario
Kart 8
but Nintendo's console has been
suffering from a lack of realistic
racing games that is until now
[Music]
gear club unlimited comes from veteran
developer eating games whose credits
stay back all the way to the v-rally
series on playstation one with nearly 20
years of racing game knowledge they're
looking to bring a hardcore racing sim
experience to the switch all while
balancing the game for newcomers as well
there are a lot of real-life cars in
gear Club Unlimited and you'll be able
to customize the look and performance of
each one the tuning system is pretty
in-depth allowing you to modify
everything from the size of the cars
spoiler to the tires traction as far as
the gameplay itself gear club unlimited
rides line between hardcore simulation
and arcade racer the sliders that allow
you to adjust the braking skidding and
steering can help make driving a bit
easier for newcomers but aren't by any
means required this is what eating games
is calling an accessible simulation in
that gear club unlimited manages to
offer a wealth of features customization
and straightforward driving modes all
while keeping the controls inviting for
people who just want to dip their toes
in the water first for example if you
misjudge a turn and smash into a wall by
mistake you can rewind time and try
again though you'll end up earning less
money at the end of the race and by the
way there are tons of races for you to
dig your teeth into gear Club unlimited
features four hundred races across this
vast overworld with leaks that you'll be
able to enter and compete in against up
to 50 players eating games is hoping to
foster a community around the game with
monthly online events for both rookies
and experts alike overall gear Club
unlimited is a game that looks to please
car lovers of all skill levels it may
not be the full simulation experience
like project cars - is and may even be
closer to Forza horizon in terms of its
arcade enos but the way it balances the
two seems to be its biggest
accomplishment the slick user-friendly
menus the sims inspired garage and local
multiplayer modes really help in easing
newcomers into the simulation so if
you're a racing game enthusiast or would
just prefer something a little bit more
realistic than Mario Kart on your switch
gear club and limited might be what
you're looking for
hope you guys enjoyed the preview of
gear club unlimited and for even more
recent game coverage you can check out
our review of Forza Motorsport 7 as well
as our thoughts on Gran Turismo sport or
on gamespot.com
my name is joy and thanks for watching